in the last decades of the british
empire and during the decolonization era
people from the former british colonies
still came to study at the university of
oxford as it was one of the most
advanced universities in the former
empire however this fact was a
contentious subject in the colonies
because oxford along with other english
universities of the time was by design
the place where the empire's elite and
top scholars came to study resulting in
the fact that colonial schools were
often neglected and underdeveloped
bandaranaike who later became the leader
of the sri lankan freedom party came to
study at oxford and he observed that for
all the benefits an oxford education
gives a person these are not outweighed
by the negatives of taking people from
the colonies to be educated in england
rather than in their own countries jk
chetter an indian poet who was at oxford
at the same time disagreed with this
opinion saying that the centralization
of all the brightest people in one place
was a good thing if you want to know
more check out my video on it on the
mlaser history youtube channel